hi I'm Lucy I want to make education fun
for everybody I'm 19 years old I go to
Carnegie Mellon I'm double majoring in
computer science and human computer
interactions
I guess program II and I went in second
grade I want to say I think one of the
reasons I'm one of the 25 percent of
women in tech is because I was born in a
Silicon Valley and I was exposed to tech
kind of very young age I'm going to make
an iPhone app and I actually want to add
a virtual pet component to it I learned
much more by doing rather than sitting
in a classroom I think that the reason
I'm here today is because my parents
have always said no to me and I had this
internal need to prove them wrong which
is definitely very driven
it'll be like 4:00 a.m. at some
hackathon and these really come on we're
just going at this this feature done and
this feature done it's annoying when
guys think that oh you're a girl so
you're not that technical
you're affecting someone from like
across the we're all